[موسيقى]
الوحش الأوسط الأجنبي في الرياض بالمملكة العربية السعودية
أكبر مهرجان موسيقي EDM في المنطقة
مع عروض لفنانين عالميين
مثل باستر رايمز وبرونو مارس
إلى جانب المواهب المحلية مثل كوزميك
كاروت وفنان البوب ​​الإلكتروني فلانا،
لن تتخيل شيئًا
يحدث في السعودية  مع التغيير الذي
يحدث في البلاد، ومع
حصول صناعة الموسيقى الآن على
دعم أكبر بكثير، لم نعد نشعر أننا نستمد
هذا القدر من الإلهام من مراجع
الموسيقى الغربية، فهناك الكثير من
التركيز على ما لدينا داخليًا وهو
الشيء الذي لفت انتباهي  المفاجأة هي
أنه مع وجود جميع الأسماء العالمية
هناك، كانت المراحل الأخرى أكثر
ازدحامًا بكثير حيث كان السكان المحليون
يعزفون الفولان ويعزفون في إحدى
المراحل كوزميكات على مسرح آخر، ونحن
نفضل أن نحتفل بموسيقيينا،
لذلك هناك ذلك بوند الذي كان دائمًا
هناك، مع الجميع يدعمون بعضهم البعض،
لديهم آمال كبيرة للمشهد الموسيقي السعودي
ومجتمع الفنانين،
الأمر الرائع هو الحصول على أصوات جديدة لما هي عليه
الموسيقى السعودية في الواقع، هناك
الآن موسيقى غربية ولكن
الآن هناك مثل موسيقانا وهي كذلك
ينافس على نفس المستوى
الأجنبي